[Música]
o que terá do ser humano
a nossa espécie continuará existindo
para sempre continuar existindo por
muito tempo ainda
por muito pouco a inteligência
artificial é uma ameaça uma idade ou uma
dádiva
continuamos populado o planeta terra ou
iremos para outros planetas
hoje vários autores estão debatendo
destas questões e e uma das questões
mais importantes
eu falei lembrar que é afinal o planeta
terra existe faz 4,5 bilhões de anos a
espécie homo faz 2,5 milhões de anos
vamos apenas existe faz só 200 mil anos
nada garante que tudo isso vai continuar
para sempre
por outro lado alguns autores alegam que
não fizemos nada de bom que só poluímos
o meio ambiente que destruímos o planeta
que é somos um animal como os demais
como os outros que não respeitamos os
ciclos naturais da natureza que tiramos
o habitat dos animais é uma visão muito
pessimista do ser humano e que enxerga o
ser humano como um mero parasita não
construímos nada de bom e só dois
treinos mas será que tudo isso é verdade
vamos ver os dados os números e os fatos
objetivos porque falam desde seu
aparecimento na face da terra
o ser humano viveu e estagnou na pobreza
e na miséria até mais ou menos 1800
quando a renda per capita aumentou de
forma exponencial e não só de forma
linear e progressiva
tudo isso graças a um processo histórico
chamado revolução industrial
o momento histórico que mais melhorou as
condições de vida do ser humano ao longo
da história
tudo o que nós temos hoje devemos a este
curto arco temporal a revolução
industrial
nos últimos 40 anos a a pobreza diminuiu
pela metade
é a segunda vez que a cobrança se
diminui uma forma tão rápida e tão
drástica
exatamente porque nós estamos vivendo
nesta fase nem notamos mas vai ficar nos
livros de história e não é só o efeito
china
os dados demonstram como este gráfico
que até descontando o progresso recente
da china a média mundial do mundo acaba
sendo sempre menos pobres e mais rica
a porcentagem de desnutridos nos países
pobres dos anos 70 até hoje caiu de 35 a
15% ea distribuição direta de 75 até
hoje o mundo ficou ainda mais rico em
conjunto com o aumento populacional
graças inclusive ao aumento populacional
e não apesar disso como alguns autores
eram na média acreditam e ficou ainda
menos desigual e não mais desigual
os gráficos mostram que a distribuição
direta tão rico só e não mais dois
e não é só qualidade de vida é a
expectativa de vida também a expectativa
de vida aumentou de 36 anos no arco
temporal dos últimos 110 anos
é muita coisa e é muito rápido a
mortalidade infantil vem caindo 10 anos
60 de forma contínua e consistente e
outra infantil pobreza poluição
analfabetismo e vários outros dados vêm
caindo de forma consistente continua
resultado as pessoas são mais felizes
várias pesquisas sobre percepção de
felicidade mostra que o mundo fica mais
feliz é média na margem e isso é
fortemente correlato ao aumento de renda
fique mais ricos pessoas nos privou os
problemas concretos que nós temos a
nossa vida
ficamos também mais felizes
eu sei pode parecer estranho e não
estamos acostumados
afinal se você assistir muito a mídia
noticiário
parece que todos os dias acontecem
coisas terríveis calamidades naturais
catástrofes guerras criminalidade crise
humanitárias crise econômica
na verdade tudo isso é notícia
exatamente porque o mundo está indo ao
contrário está melhorado e tudo isso é
uma exceção e se torna sempre mais geral
e nos tornamos sempre mais sensíveis é
porque o mundo mais conectado e nós
estamos mais informações sobre o mundo
inteiro explante sobre os lugares mais
remotos da terra
todas essas coisas acontecendo tem muito
mais na verdade só que nós não ficávamos
sabendo que tinha também mais pontos
para cada evento daquele tipo
o ser humano no cérebro têm um gene
pessimista e este gene pessimista faz
com que nós subestimamos os eventos
positivos e subestimamos os eventos
negativos
faz sentido evolutivo nós precisamos
disso para poder agir no mundo é evitar
os riscos e minimizar os perigos e
graças a isso que estamos aqui ainda
hoje
só que este gere não ajuda e atrapalha
no momento de fazer análises objetivas
vamos ver o que nós fizemos na verdade
nós notamos quantas coisas positivas nós
criamos e às vezes não notamos e damos
por garantidos
vamos ver várias delas em várias áreas
na arte
nós já fizemos a derrota a vênus de
botticelli o luva imitar o taj mahal os
quadros de caravaggio
dali o davi de michelangelo da música já
criamos a nona sinfonia de beethoven
rojas
frank sinatra coisa mais feia diferença
freddy mercury e as canções para ensinar
nossos filhos
na gastronomia nós já enfrentamos mais
de mil tipos de massas
a propósito a palavra macarrão errada é
massa mesmo o cannolo siciliano e adota
sete véus whisky e chocolate
nenhuma outra espécie animal inventou
chocolate e todos ficam com inveja a
literatura já escrevemos ao dicéia a
algo como a divina comédia mil e uma
noites
o príncipe de maquiavel de anéis de
tóquio no cinema e o vento levou e
técnica
[Música]
game of thrones tela
nós desafiamos a gravidade construímos
prédio sempre mais altos e arranha ceús
formas para os céus
viajamos de avião fomos para o espaço e
para a lua
ao invés da medicina fizemos passos
críveis passos gigantes
hoje nós temos vacinas que salvam
milhões e milhões de vidas
inventamos a pm celino operamos a córnea
a catarata o cristalino ao gol
simplesmente impensável alguns anos
atrás de algumas décadas atrás
nós vamos operações complexas
transplantes de órgãos inclusive hoje
meu filho está vivo graças a uma
operação similar a esta
eu já vi pessoas sendo ressuscitadas
graças a um desfibrilador
tentamos o silicone o viagra e até o
dentifrício nenhum outro animal escova
os dentes depois do almoço academia
musculação estamos tão em forma tão em
saúde e parecemos tão novos tão jovens
como nunca antes na história da economia
nós inventamos o dinheiro para aumentar
o número de trocas entre as pessoas
nenhum animal faz trocas sistêmicas e
pacíficas
ele explica que entrou em conflito se
batem para tomar os bens dos demais
inventamos os mercados onde os dois
lados falam o duplo obrigado o comprador
ou vendedor fala obrigado esse programa
mede os contratos para garantir os
negócios ea palavra dada
os bancos para guardar e proteger o
dinheiro de quem tem emprestá-lo para
quem não tem senão continuar ia ficando
sem dinheiro
as bolsas de valores para financiar as
empresas e gerar mais renda mais emprego
e mais riqueza
na moda nós inventamos nos vestimos com
tecidos finos aos quais estamos
acostumados e parecem normais como
algodão certa lá e cache mesmo sapato
somos o único animal a não andar
descalço e não só sábados básicos
simples funcionais são sapatos lindos
que fica na moda que trocamos era
continuar na sede para sapatos sensuais
com salto alto
o smart das mulheres o perfume
descobrimos inventarmos os números do
zero o infinito
os números primos descobrimos o pib
grego ea matemática de forma geral é
graças a ela que todos nossos prédios
tecnológicos eletrônicos funcionam o
computador por exemplo e graças a ela
que fomos até o espaço
nós dominamos a natureza construímos
pontes para superar rios e juntar
montanhas diques para parar os rios e
produzir energia túneis para passar por
baixo e por dentro das montanhas
fertilizantes para poder produzir mais
comida de forma mais barata mais
acessível aumentar a renda dos
agricultores e vender a comida mais
barata e alimentar mais pessoas
esquecidas para proteger as nossas
plantas de pragas e doenças e alimentar
as pessoas sem placas quando essas de
forma mais saudável e organismos
geneticamente modificados
exatamente para evitar usar realizadas
pesquisas para produzir comida mais
barata e mais acessível aumentará nos
produtores e alimentar mais pessoas ao
redor do mundo
inventamos o fogo para iluminar as
noites para nós defender das feras e
cozinhar a comida um churrasco um bom
churrasco
nós temos a condicionado nos dias nos
dias quentes e estamos até aquecer dó
frios
temos serras para produzir flores
plantas detalhes e para tomate fora de
estação e nós nem notamos isso somos o
único animal que fala promete com
línguas complexas e várias línguas
diferentes ao redor do mundo e na
linguagem inventamos palavras lindas
como getam saudade bisnagas céu da boca
notem que poesia para definir
simplesmente uma paixão platônica wafa
curu nasce s/a também fizemos passos
gigantes
nós temos energia luz gás e petróleo
para iluminar as noites e ativar todos
os maquinários que nos auxilia nos ajuda
no dia a dia sem hélices todos nós
estaríamos perdidos e um motor para
fazer funcionar todas essas máquinas
nós inventamos plástico naylon e
máquinas como máquina de lavar que
liberaram as pessoas do trabalho manual
do trabalho cansativo trabalho em casa
nós enfrentamos computadores ita
permitem conectar o mundo inteiro os
lugares mais remotos fazendo coisas e
previsíveis incríveis e op nós
consideramos normais nós criamos livros
bibliotecas universidades
somos o único animal que escreve livros
e que estuda
nós inventamos o sport somos um único
animal também que sua e compete por mero
prazer
o beijo é o casamento dos animais
acasala mas só ser humano faz uma festa
deste tipo com vida as paredes
[Música]
o funeral é um momento triste verdade
mas nenhum animal se despede e celebra
os carros que se formam fotografias para
imortalizar os momentos lindos e lembrar
nossos caros
nós temos férias somos o único animal
que consegue tirar férias
os outros trabalha sete dias por semana
e nós viajamos o único animal que
consegue viajar por prazer e não por
mera necessidade
o parque é o domingo com as crianças e
festas
vário hoje festas nós damos um abrigo
nosso filho protejamos hélices dos
momentos ruins e complicados e das
adversidades da vida
eu não sei exatamente qual vai ser o
futuro da humanidade
eu não sei se como vamos lidar com
inteligência artificial
iremos sucumbir às fundir com ela ou
alguma coisa do tipo
não sei se conseguiremos popular deste
planeta ou iremos para outros mas eu sei
o que nós fizemos até agora fizemos
coisas grandiosas que os outros animais
sequer imaginam
nós somos o único que conseguiu subir na
cadeia alimentar que conseguiu liminar
naturais atendido positivo para si mesmo
para o bem que conseguiu melhora da
planan disso para o edurant da
humanidade
o bem material ou bem material do qual
usamos é devido é este grande processo
de prosperidade e tudo isso acho que
merece o hino
obrigado
[Aplausos]